invité à présent Michel placier bonsoir
à vous bonsoir vous êtes revenu sur ce
plateau vous êtes délégué cfe-cgt CGC
pardon Renault et ça change tout c'est
Renault Technocentre votre syndicat qui
contrairement d'ailleurs à la CGT a
décidé de signer cet accord de
compétitivité proposée par la direction
il y a eu des concessions de fait on va
revenir sur les différents points de cet
accord tout d'abord quelques précisions
avec ce reportage de la rédaction
le timing est parfait le jour où le
gouvernement adopte le projet de loi sur
l'accord interprofessionnel Renault
obtient la signature de deux syndicats
pour entériner son projet de
compétitivité après la CFE CGC Force
Ouvrière lui emboîté le pas ce mercredi
déjà on sait qu'on a gagné il y a trois
ans et
au bout de ces trois ans on sait très
bien que Henri on nous parle de 2016
dans un premier temps voir 2020 donc moi
je dirais qu'on est déjà pratiquement
garanti jusqu'en 2020 bon on risque de
faire des voitures de nos partenaires
Nissan et puis certainement démarre la
direction de la marque colosange
s'engage à ne fermer aucun site et à ne
pas adopter de plan social pour y
arriver l'accord prévoit d'augmenter la
production française avec au moins 710
000 véhicules par an dont 110 000 à
l'usine de Flins en contrepartie les
salariés acceptent d'augmenter leur
rythme de travail passant de 32 à 35
heures et de voir leur salaire gelé en
2013 contrairement à la volonté de
l'entreprise
malgré ses engagements pris jusqu'en
2016 la CGT reste fermement opposée au
projet au-delà de ces deux véhicules Zoé
et Clio 4 qui sont produits sur l'usine
de Flins aujourd'hui dans l'avenir plus
lointain au-delà de 2016 il n'y a pas de
véhicule aujourd'hui dans les tiroirs de
Renault qui pourrait rentrer dans
l'usine de Flins d'ici à 2016 plus de
8200 postes seront tout de même
supprimés le projet sera présenté le 12
mars en conseil central d'entreprise il
pourrait être signé dès le lendemain
elle est syndicats donc un cfe-cgcf au
CFDT qui donne l'orphe vert trois
syndicats qui représentent 64% des
salariés du constructeur l'accord de
compétitivité va donc être signée dès
demain 13 mars expliquez-nous pourquoi
avoir accepté alors que certains
syndicats comme la CGT par exemple
refusent bien écoutez aujourd'hui on
voit tous que le marché automobile est
en crise et que en fait d'un marché
conjoncturellement mauvais ça devient
structurellement mauvais donc il fallait
que qu'on fasse quelque chose donc on
peut se lamenter et crier mais aussi on
peut se mettre autour de la table et
discuter avec la direction afin de
pouvoir pérenniser Renault votre point
de vue sur l'attitude de la CGT
justement qui refuse toujours de signer
cet accord même si c'est un syndicat
minoritaire pour écouter chaque
organisation syndicale se détermine
comme elle le souhaite mais la CGT ne
nous a pas habitué à signer des accords
donc je suis pas surpris du tout qu'elle
ne signe pas d'accord elle a des points
clés on va revenir un petit peu sur les
différents points de cet accord c'est la
mobilité entre usine notamment la
direction voulait au tout début que ce
soit obligatoire cette mobilité des
salariés et finalement ce sera sur une
base de volontariat c'est ce que vous
avez obtenu un point qui nous chagrenait
beaucoup c'était cette mobilité
opposable et donc on a demandé à obtenu
que toutes les mobilités soient faites
uniquement volontariat de façon à
pouvoir équilibrer les effectifs dans
les usines en cas de croissance ou de
décroissance des volumes dans les usines
considérés et pour vous c'est
satisfaisant cette base de données
ce point était un point bloquant si on
n'avait pas obtenu ce point là notre
signature était quand même un peu
compromise et même si celle sur la base
du volontariat vous n'avez pas peur que
l'on pousse en tout cas que l'on incite
ses salariés à nous obliger d'une usine
à une autre ça sera à nous donc dans les
dans les usines et puis avec la
commission de suivi l'Observatoire qu'on
a également obtenu lors de cet accord de
veiller à ce que les engagements soient
bien pris soit bien
effectué et qu'il n'y ait pas de dérive
de la part de certains certaines
personnes dans les usines il y a un
point symbolique également auquel
beaucoup de salariés sont forcément
attaché les salaires je les pour pour
2013 l'augmentation ensuite sur
2014-2015 ce sera discuté lors des
discussions annuelles comment on arrive
à convaincre des salariés de d'un gel de
salaire alors d'abord au départ le
maintien de la masse salariale sur 2013
avait été
une condition sinequanone et écrite dans
l'accord on a obtenu qu'elle soit
sortie elle est toujours dans l'accord
mais elle est moins prégnant dans la
corde de façon à ce que les NAO les
négociations annuelles obligatoires et
toutes leurs forces cette année et donc
on va se remettre à table pour négocier
avec la direction notamment vous
pourriez obtenir éventuellement des
augmentations de salaire sur 2014-2015
quand on voit la conjoncture actuelle ça
semble compliqué aussi la première
version de la Corse était écrit dans le
dur qu'on avait 0 % on a réussi quand
même à montrer qu'il y avait des NAO et
à redonner de la force au Nao on va
négocier on essaiera d'opté venir mieux
que zéro ou peut-être 0 mais dans la vie
il faut essayer en tout cas la porte est
ouverte
je on a on a on a beaucoup d'espoir sur
les négociations annuelles de cette
année avant de continuer à regarder les
différents points de cet accord qui pose
des problèmes et puis ceux qui
finalement ont permis de se mettre
d'accord avec la direction juste un
micro-trottoir accepteriez-vous un gel
de salaire en ce qui vous concerne pour
préserver votre emploi
ça dépend des conditions qui vont
ensemble mais je pense si c'est chômage
bien sûr je prendrai le gel du salaire
j'accepterai peut-être mais pas
faut pas que ça soit gros quoi
aujourd'hui oui je pense que je serai
prêt justement à faire des concessions
sur mon salaire si vraiment mon
entreprise allait mal ça fait à peu près
4 ans que mon salaire réglé donc
je peux continuer encore deux ans oui
non pas à mon niveau non pas du tout je
suis trop peu payé pour accepter un gel
de salaire puis à l'âge que j'ai si je
commence à je démonte ça allait en
maintenant
je suis mal barré oui pourquoi pas oui
pourquoi pas pour aider l'entreprise je
pense que je pense qu'il faut avoir
l'esprit d'entreprise avant tout et se
soutenir les uns les autres voilà
finalement les gens sont opposés mais
ils peuvent comprendre que pour
préserver l'emploi il faut faire des
efforts et c'est un petit peu le mot clé
aussi il faut faire des efforts et puis
on voit aujourd'hui vous regardez les
informations et vous voyez ce qui se
passe chez les constructeurs qui n'ont
pas négocié à temps ou qui n'ont pas eu
des organisations syndicales qui ont
permis de négocier d'une façon
responsable comme nous nous le faisons
la CGC et on arrive à des à des
extrémités à des fermetures d'usine à
des licenciements ce que nous nous
n'avons aucun licenciement je tiens à le
redire ce soir il y a aucun licencie les
postes de départ il y aura des postes il
y aura
8360 postes de supprimer il y a 860
embauches donc
ce sont des gens la majorité vont partir
dans un
dispositif de cessation d'activité et
permettre de d'être chez eux à 75% de
leur salaire pendant trois ans maximum
donc tout en restant aux effectifs mais
ça permettra de maintenir l'activité
pour la société Renault et de ne pas
fermer d'usines par exemple le flanc
nous sommes dans le département des
Yvelines le site de Flins était
notamment au début des négociations
c'était pas c'était pas du tout gagné
qu'on ait une voire deux usines qui ne
ferment pas et en effet Flins était dans
été dans le dans le dans ces mesures
possibles donc là nous avons obtenu des
volumes
significatifs dans les usines les usines
aujourd'hui sont chargées entre 50 et
60% de leur capacités et avec l'accord
que l'on va signer demain les usines
vont être chargées à peu près à 85%
donc à l'horizon 2016 nous devrions
avoir 710 710 000 véhicules mini
représentés par 630 000 véhicules plus
10000 véhicules d'autres partenaires
mais comment justement voilà c'est la
question que j'allais vous poser comment
on maintient cette activité cette
production de véhicules on fait appel à
Nissan notamment alors il y aura dans
les partenaires Nissan et pour 2016 je
tiens à Signal aussi qui on a une cible
à 820 000 véhicules tout ceci sera
regardé et analysé on a obtenu donc
l'observateur dont je parlais tout à
l'heure de façon à cette observatoire a
bien anticipé et être proactif
c'est-à-dire regarder suffisamment tôt
si tous les engagements qui ont été
signés dans cet accord peuvent être
tenus et donc de façon à pouvoir se
réunir suffisamment tôt pour essayer de
corriger on est vraiment décidé à
pérenniser Renault à pérenniser la
filière automobile
sauvegarder les emplois dans les bassins
d'emploi je pense au bassin du Nord au
bassin de l'Ouest et puis à sauvegarder
les emplois des salariés français mais
on produit l'activité on continue à
maintenir cette activité cette
production de deux véhicules mais il va
falloir les vendre aussi ces véhicules
oui alors là je dirais aussi un pari sur
l'avenir oui là je dirais que les
voitures vont se vendre
on va avoir une gamme très attractive on
recharge on vient changer notre notre
responsable du design on a une gamme
très attractive faudra aussi que les
Français achètent maintenant des
voitures françaises parce qu'on n'a rien
à envier au véhicule allemand si je vous
dis par exemple que la société ADAC que
la société de de réparation de dépannage
des véhicules en Allemagne sur les
autoroutes allemandes font des études
tous les ans et font un palmarès de
fiabilité des constructeurs si je vous
dis chrono est toujours en tête des
constructeurs fiables sur les autoroutes
allemandes vous me croyez non et
pourtant c'est vrai Renaud est en tête
en fiabilité et à le constructeur qui a
le moins de panne immobilisantes sur les
autoroutes allemandes c'est quand même
un bon signe alors comment vous
expliquez que les ventes soient si
difficiles bah écoutez déjà bon il y a
quand même une période de crise c'est
quand même pas facile acheter une
voiture aujourd'hui on peut toujours la
reporter l'achat d'une voiture peut
toujours se reporter de six mois un an
voir deux ans en faisant un petit peu
plus de réparation ou une vidange
supplémentaire une machine à laver qui
tombe en panne c'est déjà plus difficile
si vous dites à Madame on va reporter et
puis pendant un an tu vas laver ton ton
linge à la main
là vous allez être obligé d'acheter je
pense aussi il y a certains hommes qui
doivent le faire aussi et vous dites
mesdames je voudrais juste vous sauver
la vie parce que je pense que vous allez
avoir du mal à quitter le plateau sinon
au-delà de ça avant de vous laisser
juste te conclure en ce qui concerne le
Technocentre Renault est-ce qu'il y a
une incidence de cet accord lorsqu'il
concerne l'ingénierie la recherche le
développement avec le Technocentre à
Guyancourt alors pour l'ingénierie on va
réorganiser
va être réorganisé pour renforcer le
cœur de métier c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
on va diviser les le travail de les
fonctions d'ingénierie en coeur de
métier et non coeur de métier le cœur de
métier va rester en France va rester
incorporette au niveau de l'ingénierie
alors quand on est l'ingénierie c'est
pas forcément le Technocentre il y a
aussi Royal Hardy pour la mécanique ou
les véhicules utilitaires les véhicules
utilitaires pour vider son Frédéric donc
c'est l'ingénierie au sens global donc
le coeur de métier ça va être tout ce
qui est innovation travail à forte
valeur ajoutée tout ce qui est recherche
stratégie et tous les travaux qui sont
en phase de croissance comme les
systèmes électroniques et puis
continuer l'activité va se maintenir du
renforcer justement pour être encore
plus attractive et pouvoir sauver
Renault grâce à de l'innovation parce
que c'est ça aujourd'hui qui sauve les
entreprises c'est l'innovation merci
Michel placier nous avons
malheureusement à vous tant de
développer déléguer SFE CGC Renault à
Guyancourt et cet accord de
compétitivité qui sera signé demain nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler c'est la
fin de cette édition pour ceux qui nous
suivaient et qui voulaient en savoir
plus sur la sortie de ce jeu vidéo de la
société Blizzard l'un des leaders
mondiaux du jeu vidéo je vous propose de
vous rendre sur notre site internet
découvrir ce reportage ou tout
simplement de suivre l'actu le toute
image de la rédaction c'est à 20h30 moi
je vous retrouve demain avec de nouveaux
invités sur ce plateau des 18 heures en
direct